and all right when the four seasons
hotel collabs with neiman marcus you
know it's going to be hot okay you can
join their special afternoon on
september 24th for fall fashion trends
and tea so let's welcome amy hudson from
neiman's and also carrie noonan from the
four seasons to talk about this haute
collab first and foremost i have to say
you all look fabulous
and i love a good play on words so let's
explain hot versus hot
couture it's a play on hook tour so
we're bringing fall fashion right that
looks from the runway to the four
seasons for our fashion tea i love that
now why did you guys choose to collab
you know it's just it makes sense
to
luxury brands it's just a really great
synergy so
we're very excited that we have this
opportunity to partner with them well
speaking of synergy you have great
outfits energy right now i'm feeling it
so let's talk fall trends what is on the
list so it's all about that matched
suiting and today we have ellen here so
she's got this great suit on from alice
and olivia gorgeous but and pops of
colors and colorful prints so
very vibrant for the fall season that's
a little different right it is yeah
usually we mute it but we're popping out
okay we're popping out and it's all
about you know we're getting back to
dressing up so
we've got the great suiting the jacket
is really important this season
and then we paired it back to this
really great tote
tote bag is a really important
silhouette for the fall as well okay i
am checking girl let me let's talk after
this because i want to get that entire
suit on here and wear it on this on las
vegas now now let's talk you've been
making you've been pairing your hot tea
what is going into your drink yes so
this is a little play on a traditional
old fashioned but it is called not so
old-fashioned ah so what we've taken is
this buffalo choice bourbon and we
steeped it overnight with this really
beautiful tea right here it's a hibiscus
berry tea so we let it sit overnight so
it gets this really like rich flavor and
complexity and then that's what we use
for the base of our old fashion
traditional old-fashioned use a little
bit of sugar but instead we're using tea
or excuse me honey to keep with the
teeth um but pretty simple that's it
just those two ingredients and then we
just give it a little stir just to make
sure it's mixed well and that it's a
little bit chilled and then strain and
pour and that's about it so a little bit
nice take on the fall weather as well
simple but fabulous yes definitely
fabulous i've said that four times now
because that's all i can see here but
before we wrap up just tell everybody
what else they can enjoy on top of the
tea and the fall fast definitely how
they can get tickets of course so with
the tea show we are having a lot of
great cocktails we have tea infused
cocktails
champagne available a really nice
bourbon pairings all to go with the chef
seasonal menu so it's a traditional tea
service but definitely amped up with all
these extra goodies there's going to be
a dj playing live music will be really
fun and interactive i guess we'll get a
chance to interact with the models as
well ask them different questions what
are your shoes what are you wearing so
you could definitely say it's not your
grandmother's typical teeth not your
grandmother's teeth and really quick
websites to get tickets uh reservations
are required by telephone you can call
the fourth season 702-632-5121
perfect thank you ladies we'll be right
back on las vegas now
[Music]